[Music]
uh
[Music]
me
[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here yes that was
the rimek concept one which by the end
of this video will be the fastest car
i've ever driven
this
is the insta360 go 2 which is one of the
neatest weirdest little cameras i've
ever used but first we got to start with
the fastest drone i have ever flown
it's a lot of stuff in this video this
is dope tech all right so to
dramatically oversimplify there are
basically two types of drones the first
one is the one we've kind of all seen
and heard of
the film tool so something like this
which is dji's mavic and dji has gotten
extremely good at these and currently
leaves the space they've got the mavic 2
the spark and the phantom and all these
drones are designed to make it as easy
as possible to capture high quality
aerial footage so they've got high
quality camera systems on multi-access
gimbals they're all built in they can
run pre-programmed flight paths and they
can even follow objects automatically
they have obstacle avoidance built in
and they're easy enough to learn that
someone who's literally never flown a
drone before can pick one up and on
their first try get a pretty good smooth
4k shot because that's what they're
designed to do and then on the other
side of the fence there are fpv drones
spv standing for first person view
also commonly known as these racing
drones and you might even see them on tv
lately as espn is showing some fpv drone
races on tv now but these are much more
custom diy built quadcopters made from
kits that you can buy off the shelf
where you do a fair bit of putting
things together yourself you're tweaking
experimenting even soldering sometimes
to get it to work it's a lot more
involved but when you're done you get
this crazy sporty fun experience that is
completely manual so you're not doing
these automatic cinema shots you can rip
around obstacle courses at crazy speeds
there's going to be crashes and that's
completely normal but these kits have
replacement parts for almost every
component so if you break a propeller
just pop on a new one or if you crack an
arm you can replace that too turns out
when something's made to be broken it's
a lot easier to fix the battery life on
these things is typically only five to
nine minutes tops and the camera quality
is absolutely not a priority really it's
just there to be able to give you a
real-time feed of where the drone is
flying in space and it's usually paired
with a set of goggles that you wear so
you can fly the drone from the camera
feed like a pilot that's where the first
person view part comes in and while it's
not the highest quality footage ever it
is pretty awesome so now enter
dji's new
fpv drone it's literally called the dji
fpv that's what they named it but this
takes some of the best things from both
of these two very separate worlds of
drones and matches them together into
one so from the ones we're familiar with
in the cinema world a much better 4k
camera on a gimbal stabilized it's also
got obstacle avoidance and a relatively
easy learning curve to learn how to fly
but from the other side
well this thing is it's fast it's sporty
it rips around in these crazy agile
nimble patterns and it flies like an fpv
drone so the result combined with the
goggles is easily the most fun i've ever
had flying a drone easily like the drone
itself looks the part of course you've
got these pretty small propellers
non-collapsible arms the whole thing is
pretty compact but it's definitely in
this very aggressive shape really the
battery at the back is most of the
weight and there's a 4k stabilized
camera up front and then the last two
pieces are the goggles and the remote
the goggles are exactly what you'd
expect from the fpv world they're a low
latency transmitter and a monitor for
the drone's camera and they look like
this when you have them on so
great and they're not the most
comfortable goggles in the world either
the padding is not actually all that
soft where they sit around your face but
you got to remember they're more than
just a display
there's a whole computer in here there's
antennas for communicating with the
drone and getting that high resolution
video feed with a low enough latency to
control it quickly plus you've got some
extra controls for the camera and the
media and you can even store that
streamed video straight to a micro sd
card in the headset which is actually
really smart because if you're doing
some particularly risky maneuver over
some water or something like that and
you're not sure you're gonna be able to
recover the drone you can record the
video to the goggles in case you can't
get this card later so the headset is
powered by a battery on a cable that
goes into your pocket then the
controller is pretty simple it looks
kind of just like a mavic controller
minus the spot for your phone it's the
joysticks and an antenna really so
there's three modes for flying this
thing
normal mode which is best for beginners
it gets you the closest to the other dji
drones this one is still pretty quick
maxes out at 33 miles per hour but it's
best for shooting with the cameras
because the drone doesn't tilt very much
and the obstacle avoidance is using the
built-in sensors and it'll save you if
you go too crazy it can fly like this
for about 15 minutes on a single battery
which is an eternity in the fpv world
then
there's sport mode which unlocks a lot
more speed so this has object detection
turned off and now you're talking a max
speed of about 60 miles an hour
that's already faster than almost any
other consumer drone right now and that
lets you get those
hard turns the tight corners and the
sweet flatlines it really is a sporty
mode
it's also kind of wild how this thing
sounds as it buzzes by you or it makes
like a really sharp turn the propellers
are moving so fast it makes this really
high-pitched wine this this crazy motor
rev sound so the third and final mode is
manual mode which is fully unlocked so
no restrictions no limits it's all about
you and your control
and it's kind of insane i personally
didn't fly much in manual mode because
not only is it the hardest to learn but
it's the riskiest but you can do flips
and all kinds of moves that you can pull
off in a normal fpv drone and it's
happening at a new max speed of up to 87
miles per hour so i found it most
comfortable in sport mode to be honest
it's already faster than almost any
other drone i've used and it's so crazy
nimble and fun that it just kind of
feels like a video game it's addicting
and the video quality you can see
is really not bad i mean compared to
what you saw on the drone racing
league's youtube channel it's
practically cinema quality you've got
the stabilization from the gimbal and
there's an additional layer of eis on
top that helps smooth out the footage
and in sport mode you're gonna get the
propellers in the shot a bit more than
something like a phantom or a mavic
because it is leaning a lot further
forward and turning faster and harder so
you're going to get more of the props in
your shot but in normal mode you can use
it like a legit film tool if you want to
and slow it down get some nice shots
that's 120 megabits per second at 4k 60
with a cinematic color profile also fun
fact
we did crash this one as you can kind of
see here um but this does seem very
resilient to crashes this is the type of
drone you probably expect to crash a
couple of times uh with this one it
crashed upside down and skidded across
asphalt for a while picked it up
replaced the propellers
and it was good to go like nothing's
broken nothing doesn't work it's still
good dji also made a simulator that you
can learn to fly in before actually
taking a drone up into the sky so if you
want to explore what it means to fly in
manual mode and see whether or not
you're ready for it that is definitely
the move it's pretty cool that they
built that in and it might save you 1300
bucks but yeah like i said so fun i've
never flown an actual fpv drones and
that's probably true for most people
watching this and to me
the dji fpv represents a bit more
accessibility for that fpv experience
now don't get me wrong it's still
expensive it's still the whole kit will
be
12.99
but
if you asked me basically today if i
could only use one drone for the rest of
my life
i i think i would pick this one i think
that would be the most fun so really the
difference between getting into building
your own drone from parts and flying
around an obstacle course versus this
basically plug and play version
is pretty dramatic that's where the
accessibility comes in and that's where
it's so awesome and that's not even
mentioning the joystick controller which
is a pretty sweet alternate version
which can let you fly it around by
moving around the joystick in the air
which is
awesome
but i'll link some pretty good reviews
of this drone if you want by some
friends who have had it for longer than
me
if you want to check them out blow the
like button
now speaking of things that are the most
fun
when they go fast that blue car that you
were seeing in some of those shots
yeah that that is the remake concept one
this car
is on another level and you will
absolutely never see one of these in the
street and there's a few reasons why
okay so first there were only eight of
these ever made total and you might
actually already know the story about
how one of them doesn't exist anymore
thanks to a little top gear incident so
now there's only seven so they're going
for about 1.7 million dollars each and
they are all seven different specs seven
different paint colors which is pretty
cool they're unique in a lot of ways but
the concept one is really cool to me
because it's an aspirational car this
was the bleeding edge best possible
electric hyper car
in 2013. so all that crazy bleeding edge
aspirational stuff we see now in like
the tesla roadster or the koenigsegg
jumeirah or even a lucid air or
something like that
that's the same
mentality that rimac had with this back
in 2013. so this is a two-door roadster
as you can see with four permanent
magnet motors one at each wheel putting
out a total of 1200 horsepower and doing
zero to 60 miles per hour in 2.5 seconds
it has a two-speed gearbox with carbon
fiber paddle shifters which is
incredible and it has a 90 kilowatt hour
battery that sits basically right behind
the driver's seat for a 210 mile range
which conveniently matches the 210 mile
per hour top speed and fun fact the
glove box is the largest storage in this
entire tiny car there is no trunk there
is no frunk and today i'm going to drive
it
and give it a dug score just kidding i'm
not actually going to review it but i
did get to take it out for a few laps
around the block shout out to manhattan
motors for letting me borrow this
supercar for a few hours to just
experience this it was absolutely
terrifying and i was trying my hardest
not to do anything too crazy
but yeah what an experience
all right
so
you might know a little bit about this
car already there were only eight of
them ever made
so i'm gonna be very careful here
let's go okay
so obviously the number one thing you
notice getting into this car
is it is the lowest this is the lowest
car i've ever seen lowest car i've ever
been in
everyone who looks at it asks like what
is it because you just don't see cars
that look this low and it's obvious that
there's something special
but driving it
there's no other way to describe it it
feels like a go-kart
it is
so compact
there is no rear view mirror
there's no rear visibility
there's very small side mirrors
everything about the car is very small
but as you feel the steering and the
driving of it it's it's just like a
go-kart if you've ever driven a go-kart
you know what i'm talking about
now the fun part is
you've heard of the quad
motors
you know that there's crazy numbers but
there's also just like a feeling
and a sound but a feeling to driving
this which is
kind of crazy and then you have
two gears
here's the thing about the gears
i don't know when to switch between them
you have the first gear
which sounds
this is the lowest
gear ratio you're blasting off the line
your early speed stuff and then you have
gear two
which is your higher speed that's going
to go up to your 211 miles an hour
but there's no rpm indicator just power
indicators i don't really know when to
switch gears i just i would just when it
feels about right
i'm not a professional driver though so
don't do what i
do feeling of changing gears is so sick
it's so sick
this is my i'm doing my best doug demero
impression right now
oh my god
oh my god
every little bump is amplified you feel
like your roll i feel like i might be
lower than an actual skateboard because
all the batteries are behind me instead
of below me
but there's there's nothing else i've
driven that's anywhere near this i've
driven the mclaren 720s if you've seen
that video
very different in a lot of ways
but this is even lower than that which
is crazy
there's a ton of there's a ton of top
gear knowledge you might expect to hear
about a car like this but in the one or
two days i actually have with it
it's mostly just the visual for me all
the air scoops all the ventilation all
the aero
this thing slices through the air
you can also because it's not a loud
engine here every single little
piece of like a rock or something that
goes through the wheel well
[Music]
[Music]
there's something about being this close
to the ground that
makes it feel faster than it is i'm
looking at the speedometer
and we're on we're on a closed road
we're not on a highway i'm not going 100
miles an hour but it feels like i'm
going way faster
and
i know for a fact that my car is
technically on paper faster to 60 than
this
this feels faster
oh my gosh
this might not have actually technically
been the fastest thing i've ever driven
but it feels like the fastest thing i've
ever driven
by the way all the interior footage you
just saw was captured by this
tiny little camera right here this is
what i mentioned at the beginning of the
video it's the insta360 go to
it's about the only camera that would
fit in that incredibly small cabin so i
want to give it a shout out for that but
also i've been thinking a lot lately
about how i want these little tiny
cameras these 360 cameras to get better
quickly because they are so convenient
and i mean who wouldn't want that so
this go to has the best video quality of
anything they've made but also because
it's so tiny it has a bunch of other
cool convenient features y'all already
know i love magnets this camera has
magnets inside it so it can be slapped
onto other metal surfaces or you can
actually use this magnetic chest mount
necklace thing so this little thing has
a magnet built in so what you do is you
just wear it like a normal necklace
somewhere under your shirt
and there you go there's your chest
mount the case it comes in is tiny it
looks like a slightly swollen air pods
case maybe but there's a whole camera in
there and it's a multi-use case so it
charges the camera up to three times
over and it can act as a tripod if you
wanted to i actually got this in-car
first-person footage by clipping it to a
headband and honestly first-person views
are rarely done well it's one of those
camera angles that i feel like i see on
youtube more than anywhere else but i
use them a lot i use them for smartphone
reviews all the time because it gives
you that feeling like you're holding the
phone in your own hand which is the
point of that angle so in a tiny car
like this most cameras straight up don't
fit between me and the steering wheel so
as i do more car videos i want to be
able to give you that same first person
feeling as if you're literally driving
the car with me and so i've done weird
versions of this before held a
smartphone in my hand held a gopro in my
mouth once for a video and even tried
holding a red komodo with one hand but
that's not exactly safe it's not ideal
but yeah this i just tucked into my
headband and wore it around my head and
didn't even think about it so shout out
to insta360 for that i'll link the go to
if you want to check this one out down
below but also let's collectively cross
our fingers and hope that these little
action cameras and 360 cameras continue
to get better over time because i can
see a lot of use cases where this is
going to be very useful for me
especially as we do more car videos oh
and this is also uh probably a pretty
good opportunity to mention that i'll be
collaborating a little bit more
officially with top gear so you guys
might have seen the tweet announcement
but yes more car videos i'm going to be
writing for top gear magazine and
they're going to be helping out with the
videos for the autofocus series on the
channel so we might even appear in each
other's videos at some point which would
be cool but figured i'd get that
official announcement into this video
which is super exciting so either way
that's been it thanks for watching this
dope tech on
small
fast
fun lightweight objects
and uh this has been a fun one catch you
guys in the next video
peace